mike is with us mike is in
pittsburgh hey mike welcome to the dave
ramsey show hello
thank you for taking uh my call sure
just i'm looking for some guidance
um our family to start off has been
blessed financially so
it's a good call but um i have four kids
my oldest has just graduated college
yay um and she's gonna come back home
and work at a job for a couple years
um it's what she wants to do and then
she's going to move on
okay um so here's here's my question now
i have saved
um all my kids have college education so
she
she's graduating debt-free so she'll be
21 debt free
um but i do have some investments that i
started when when she was younger with
u.s savings bonds and then
i have an upma uh account uh for her
so all together i have about fifty
thousand dollars for her
um i'm not sure exactly
i know when she's 21 she's supposed to
you know i don't she does not know about
it yet but uh
i i hate to just give her this money um
is there something
you know that i saved for her uh
any kind of and then she wants to get a
car i refused to let her get a car loan
i didn't know if i used that money to
get a car
yeah and then the last thing of all that
is now she's living
i want her to get used to paying bills
and stuff so i didn't know if i would
make
do i charge her rent collect it and then
give it to her when whenever she moves
in two years
but what what can i do with that money
now all my kids are i'm gonna have that
same thing with all four kids hopefully
um so i just want to get your guidance
on that okay
uh well there's several subjects going
on here and i had every one of those
subjects with my kids and my kids are
now in their 30s
okay one's 29 and the rest of them are
30s and they're all married and
grandbabies and all kinds of good stuff
happen now so uh
all uh two of mine never came back home
they didn't want to they weren't mad at
us they just
had other plans right one of them just
got married right out of school or just
before getting out of school so
rachel winston got married right before
graduation so they obviously weren't
going to live with us or not obviously
but they chose
they were able to uh my oldest when she
did move back in with us after college
uh but we didn't want her to stay a long
time
uh just long enough to get situated she
stayed about three months
and the reason we didn't want her to
stay longer than about three months
assuming
that there wasn't some kind of a problem
in her life
and there wasn't she was a very healthy
and everything was fine and making good
money and just like yours
is something happens when they have to
turn off the lights in their own
place and buy their own groceries for
their own refrigerator
and pay the bill or it gets cut off kind
of thing
and just even with a responsible kid
something happens developmentally
they like to finish the last step into
adulthood i wouldn't let her stay there
two years
i don't think it's wise from a
developmental standpoint i think she
needs to move on with her life
now a few months is fine that's okay and
yes i would talk to her about this money
and talk to her about how to wisely use
this money that you've got as a blessing
and buy a car out of it help her go show
her how to buy a car go with her
teach her how to buy a car dad it's one
good thing dads can do
right and so uh just walk along with
that that's exactly how we did it
but you're trying to help them launch
not trying to run an economic
model there's a difference this is the
dave ramsey show